like that super tactical but I don't
know where you can say : where do I
start
what do you want to eBay completed items
certainty Bey app cert literally [ __ ]
I'm gonna show how you fell friggin do
anything off
you got your prospective
I want to be happy don't you want to be
happy right frankly I think my little
brother song okay I think straight up
the way we grew up
Hargrove now is completely totally
different because things got better
financial is and have moved me to
generational I I had to buy my car at a
garage sale
my younger brother my brother was 11
years younger than me how what's the
difference here
he's 15 I'm 26 right so they'll 11 years
same [ __ ] yes I lived this life when I
was 26
my brother was 15 but you don't need to
cast judgment on your brother like of
course I thought my brother was soft
Astin I work every minute
yeah don't cast judgment on him he's
your [ __ ] brother spent knowledge to
him so that he can think for himself but
don't judge him how am I gonna listen to
me
he's 15 is gonna pick up [ __ ] about you
he's like [ __ ] you bro I got my [ __ ] you
get you you I'll tell you how you get
him to listen I didn't cast judgment on
my brother I loved my brother and I was
like yo this is what happens in the
streets corporate right and then I let
him if he feels you're casted judgment
on him if you're always playing the oh
you're soft
I had it hard he's not gonna listen if
you're like yo I just want you to be
happy because I love you let me tell you
how this looks or that looks now you're
giving him love instead of judgment then
he'll start listening to you instead of
saying [ __ ] you bro I don't need to hear
you judging me I couldn't I didn't
control that I was born second because
it goes deeper good he doesn't have
positive mass for the energy in this leg
okay let's call around get it single mom
for kids I get it it's part of that
group just like look look look it's a
hard heartedness that the hardest thing
is when you love somebody and you're
putting them on also knowing it might
make them soft and they don't know how
to go earn for themselves
that's a fine balance that every brother
every sister every parent has to go
through you just have to be thoughtful
about it and be patient about it and
also remember how you were at 15 is done
a million different things go through
this dome
that's pretty much it all I got my man
man I appreciate just love love will
bubble you know
that's all I got doing it we go speedy
man real quick real pleasure so right
now I have a line and I recently do like
everything myself like
my problem now is really defining
whatever actually care about it is hot
they won't right now
nobody should care about it if you want
her or him to care as much give them 50%
of the [ __ ] business
they shouldn't care as much and you got
to realize you work for them they don't
work for you
scaling is about doing the thing that
everybody thinks reverse you work for
that they shouldn't care I don't expect
these guys to care as much as I do
how do you know they're u5 you hire fast
and you and you pick you hire fast and
you fire fast speed you hired him you
think he's gonna be great
he's suction you fire him you hired him
you think he's gonna be great he's great
he gets his sight you hire her you think
she's gonna be yeah then she's [ __ ]
awesome she gets to say it's about
making decisions
if you want it that's what you got to do
obviously content content yes launching
a company that's based on all this
I Balder than fashion yes is there
anything else that
to kind of accentuate my brand more just
for content more current is constant
it's so simple it's so simple no but
nobody wants to wait nine years
you don't want to wait nine years if you
know you don't to wait nine years I'm in
this for the absolutely long so that's
so there is no other secrets no other
there's make content and be good at
distribution and keep watching new
platforms and do it on every platform
and rinse and repeat and at this point
you know we have 22,000 followers on
Instagram whether you set zero or twenty
two million it would still be the same
answer same [ __ ] it's the same [ __ ] so
you're doing better than somebody with
seven not as good as some of these 49
you know and if that doesn't even mean
anything in the first place it's just
it's just constant motion to what you're
trying to achieve which I assume is for
it to be a sustainable thing for you to
live your life by doing what you love
well if you want to do that then like
the - you know people use followers or
dollars as metrics to me it's just about
being able to be sustainable
when I was building Wine Library what I
needed was $40,000 a year to pay my
$2,000 rent and buy nothing else and
that's what was sustainable so I was
able to take every other dollar to build
bigger wine laughs you're not about
getting like some fancy shoes I don't
give a [ __ ] much twenty-two thousand
followers or twenty-two million dollars
you can make twenty two million dollars
a year and spend 24 million and go out
of business yes exactly that's what
sustainability for your sustainability
got it how are you good thanks things
are amazing it's a great thing to be
here to see you thank you
one question in regards to reach a lot
about like just knowing you and doing
your feet yes created that one thing I
recently came across the term
yes which I realize is
like my entire life I've never been able
to just focus on
like if I get in that satisfaction
one thing I always got to then ship to
another thing I'm kind of like that yeah
I see that very much yeah and my
question would be like when you're a
solopreneur yeah and you're trying to
build up a branch out in that regard how
do you a t-38 put a hundred put a
hundred percent of your energy into
something that makes 80% of the macro so
that it gives you the stability to go be
conspicuous with your other 20% okay I
always had wine library or vaynermedia
yeah as a foundation that allowed me to
be ridiculous about everything else then
it becomes practical yeah otherwise if
you never create a foundation yes then
you're vulnerable so pick the thing
that's gonna be the most practical to
start build that make it solid and then
dabble in everything else it's not those
build up over time I like that
yeah it gives you the air cut each [ __ ]
to build a foundation to let you play in
perpetuity yes
thank you a couple months ago I said
entrepreneurship
yes and like I got everybody come
accomplish I love it I had a question
when I go
yes and I was one
go intern for Virgil or Shawn your whole
life right now should be about getting
internships from people that you want to
be like because the closer you get to
the Sun the more likely you could become
it
your whole life for the next eight years
should be about interning for the people
that you want to become it's the number
one move you understand cool do that and
you're the start with Virgil and Shawn
and they're not gonna reply to your DM
but you're gonna let you're gonna hit up
Jerry dilorenzo you know couldn't let
Renzo next next beat NEX it but
somebody's gonna say yes and you start
at the number 44 person you wanted and
the next summer you get to number 22
because you worked for number 44 right
champion wasn't fresh four years ago
right yeah so be smart you understand
[Music]
everything at night at night you should
be laying in bed at night searching like
hats how do you think I figured out one
life oh I was like I see a lot of mugs
at garage sales do mugs sell for
anything search on eBay mugs completed
items sold sort by sort by bucket price
holy [ __ ] there's an eighty eight dollar
mugs there's 60 $50 bucks
there's $96 month's let go buy a bunch
of mugs for a quarter come home we'll
come up educate educate educate the key
to flip light is the homework you do at
night from 10:00 to midnight during the
week that you [ __ ] then leverage on
Saturday when you kill it with your
[ __ ] knowledge that's friggin
tactless look like that super tacky no
but I don't know where you think don't
like where do I start
what do you want to eat my completed
items on ebay app like literally [ __ ]
I'm gonna show myself or you know
ready so no eBay right okay
okay now you're going to garage sales
you're like oh [ __ ] I see a lot of salt
and pepper shakers right salt and pepper
shakers you're like I see a lot of them
then you go to filter sold and completed
items
highest price and then you're like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
$441 600,000 like this little bird is
325 you're not buying this little
[ __ ] bird at a [ __ ] garage so if
you don't know it's $350 who bought move
on this returning to the salt and pepper
shaker [ __ ] collector why would
people buy sliders for 500 they collect
them a lot of people buy shirts they
collect them why do people buy bracelets
they like them people buy everything
everything could be flipped
but that's the homework that's it you go
to garage sales you go to third stores
you see a lot of things you go by the
way that's what you used to do now you
can just do it at the [ __ ] garage
sale you're like let me look that it's
like in their [ __ ] mouth in the horse
of her house you're just looking it up
in their face
[Music]
you